Oh what is going on YouTube check it out
personally if you know me I'm not one to
judge people by just Norwood if you know
one thing about living in LA is that
fashion always changes and I have seen
some weird [ __ ] and I need some [ __ ] Oh
where'd you go you won't have a penis
caught in the side of your head that's
cool dude ya know you an actual [ __ ]
is what you tell me okay that's cool I'm
not gonna give you fashion advice but
check it out just because somebody says
something's in fashion it doesn't mean
it looks good so y'all know what it is
LGI's done let's get let's go get some
simple advice just because it looks good
on someone else it doesn't mean it looks
good on you to my beautiful bigger
ladies there are certain things you
should wear and for the love of God you
should not wear for example why would
you wear a see-through mesh shirt do you
realize that you are walking around
looking like a bag of onions true story
I was walking around the city Elaine
when I saw this linebacker woman come
out of the club wearing a see-through
top and I made her what the [ __ ] have
mercy face when she saw my facial
expression do you know what she said to
me use me Asian boy don't be hating on
me because a [ __ ] be looking fresh
[ __ ] the only thing fresh about you is
if you were caught fresh out the ocean
looking like a National Geographic
special looking like Shamu hood rat
cousin shem equal your dirty ass filthy
McNasty
why is it that every single dude in LA
has to wear a v-neck look oh hey Phoenix
but that [ __ ] has a limit son the me ask
you something how low can your v-neck go
do you realize that after a certain
point your v-neck just turns into a
[ __ ] dress
Jennifer Lopez looking mother people who
should have we're super low Phoenix men
with breasts and I know what you
thinking you figured I've been
discriminatory but let me tell you
something when you are going out with
your girl she should be the only one
showing cleavage carry man with no
Phoenix don't do it nobody wants to see
food stuck in that Osama bin Laden thing
you call chest hair parsley I have
labeled that [ __ ] as a Code Red national
trend I call it visual terrorism skinny
jeans my god if you are the dude you and
my size should not be wearing the same
set of pants how you going with a
flesh-colored khakis it hasn't be skin
tight
you look like a naked Ken doll people
ask how do you know if your jeans are
too skinny why don't you ask yourself a
few questions first does it take 15
minutes to put on your pants does it
take fifty minutes to take off your
pants cannot see the outline of your
cell phone and your keys through your
pocket can you put cell phone and keys
in your pocket can others see your moose
knuckle and your Manito did you have to
chop off your dick before you put on
your pants if all this is true y'all
[ __ ] is too skinny at the end of the day
I understand it's about how you feel and
if you feel the Nexus style that you got
a pimp to do what you got to do player
but if you're not up to date and fashion
don't feel bad because not everything in
fashion looks that great in my opinion
here's a little thing about me always
socks and flip-flops and I think it's
cool right look look see right there
it's kind of cute right got a little
ninja turtle then going on right right
well now I'm self-conscious it's not go
like in front you know you know the
economy is bad when your life come down
to this god damn let's look what is
going on put a shirt on homie got no
shirt on what's up Ari chic but here's a
little thing just because someone says
it looks good it doesn't mean it does
okay that's all you [ __ ] make sense
what you think it you think I'm being
described uh this discriminatory all
right don't do that